[संगीत]
राष्ट्रपति महोदया आपकी आज्ञा है तो रक्षा
अलंकरण समारोह प्रारंभ किया
जाए शत्रु का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय असा
धारण वीरता के लिए कीर्ति चक्र मरण उपरांत
इंस्पेक्टर दिलीप कुमार
दास हेड कनस्टेबल
राजकुमार
यादव कांस्टेबल बबलू राभा एवं कांस्टेबल
शंभू रॉय 210 कोब्रा बटालियन केंद्रीय
रिजर्व पुलिस बल मरणोपरांत
3 अप्रैल 2021 माओवादियों की मौजूदगी की
सूचना के आधार पर छत्तीसगढ़ स्थित बीजापुर
के घने जंगलों में एक संयुक्त अभियान
चलाया गया माओवादियों द्वारा बैरल ग्रेनेड
लंचर तथा अन्य स्वचालित हथियारों से अचानक
किए गए तीव्र हमले का मुंह तोड़ जवाब देते
हुए अभियान दल ने तुरंत मोर्चा संभाला 6
घंटे से अधिक चली इस भीषण मुठ भेड़ में
पांच सशस्त्र माओवादियों को मार गिराया
गया एवं उनके पास से हथियार मैगजीन तथा
गोला बारूद बरामद किया गया अडिग इच्छा
शक्ति अदम्य साहस एवं अनुकरणीय कर्तव्य
निष्ठा का परिचय देते हुए इंस्पेक्टर
दिलीप कुमार दास हेड कांस्टेबल राज कुमार
यादव कांस्टेबल बबलू राभा एवं कांस्टेबल
शंभू रॉय ने आखिरी सास तक लड़ते हुए देश
के लिए अपना सर्वोच्च बलिदान दिया सम्मान
ग्रहण करेंगे उनके परिवार जन श्रीमती
प्रांजली दास धर्म पत्नी स्वर्गीय श्री
दिलीप कुमार दास
श्रीमती ज्ञानमती यादव धर्मपत्नी स्वर्गीय
श्री राजकुमार
[प्रशंसा]
यादव स्वर्गीय श्री बबलू राभा की धर्म
पत्नी श्रीमती लिपिका राभा तथा माता
श्रीमती कल्याणी
राभा स्वर्गीय श्री शंभू रॉय की माता
श्रीमती अंजलि रॉय एवं पिता श्री दजो राज
रॉय
[प्रशंसा]
सिपाही पवन कुमार द ग्रेनेडियर पच बटालियन
राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स मरणोपरांत
सिपाही पवन कुमार 27 फरवरी 2023 को कश्मीर
के पुलवामा जिले में चलाए गए आतंक विरोधी
अभियान में एक खोजी दस्ते का नेतृत्व
संभाल रहे थे उत्कृष्ट रणनीति कुशलता के
साथ अभेद्य घेराबंदी सुनिश्चित करने के
बाद वह ं ही लक्षित मकान में घुसे वहां
छिपे आतंकियों ने ग्रेनेड फेंकते हुए अंधा
धुंद गोलियां बरसानी शुरू कर दी अपने
साथियों को प्राणघातक खतरे के बीच व
निडरता से आगे बढ़े एक आतंकी का हथियार
छीन हुए उसे बेहद नजदीक से मार गिराया तथा
दूसरे आतंकी को घायल कर दिया गंभीर रूप से
जख्मी होने के बावजूद यह शूरवीर सैनिक
आखिरी सास तक आतंकियों का मुकाबला करते
हुए अंततः वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए सम्मान
ग्रहण करेंगी स्वर्गीय सिपाही पवन कुमार
की माता श्रीमती भजन दसी एवं पिता श्री
शिशुपाल
[प्रशंसा]
कैप्टन अंशुमन सिंह दामी मेडिकल कोर 26
बटालियन पंजाब रेजीमेंट मरणोपरांत
कैप्टन अंशुमन सिंह ऑपरेशन मेघदूत के
अंतर्गत सिचन ग्लेशियर में चिकित्सा
अधिकारी के रूप में तैनात थे आपने 19
जुलाई 2023 को वहां स्थित चंदन ड्रॉपिंग
जोन में हुई भीषण अग्नि दुर्घटना के दौरान
नजदीकी की फाइबर ग्लास हट में फंसे लोगों
को सुरक्षित बाहर निकालने में मदद की इसी
दौरान मेडिकल इन्वेस्टिगेशन शेल्टर को आग
की चपेट में आता देख व अपने प्राणों की
परवाह ना करते हुए उसमें कूद पड़े ताकि
जीवन रक्षक दवाइयों और उपकरणों को बचाया
जा सके तकरीबन 177000 फीट की ऊंचाई पर चल
रही तेज हवाओं के कारण आग की निरंतर बढ़ती
लपटों ने पूरे शेल्टर को अपनी गिरफ्त में
ले लिया और भरसक प्रयासों के बावजूद
उन्हें बचाया नहीं जा सका कैप्टन अंशुमन
सिंह ने असाधारण बहादुरी एवं त्याग का
परिचय देते हुए देश हित में अपना सर्वोच्च
बलिदान दिया सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगी उनकी
धर्म पत्नी श्रीमती स्मृति एवं माता
श्रीमती मंजू सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
हवलदार अबदुल माजिद नोमी बटालियन द
पैराशूट रेजिमेंट स्पेशल फोर्सेस
मरणोपरांत
हवलदार माजिद 22 नवंबर 2023 को कश्मीर में
राजौरी के ने जंगलों में चलाए गए खोजी
अभियान में स्पेशल फोर्स के दल का हिस्सा
साथ अपने प्राणों की परवाह नाना करते हुए
आपने आतंकवादियों से हुई एक अन्य मुठ भेड़
में घायल अधिकारी को सुरक्षित स्थान पर
पहुंचाया पैर में गोली लगने से बुरी तरह
जख्मी होने के बावजूद निडरता से आगे बढ़ते
हुए एक प्राकृतिक गुफा में छिपे आतंकियों
के अत्यंत निकट पहुंच गए अत्यधिक रक्त
स्राव एवं गहन पीड़ा के बीच गुफा के अंदर
एक ग्रेनेड फेंकते हुए अपने सटीक निशाने
से एक कट्टर आतंकी को मार गिराया
प्राणघातक परिस्थितियों में अद्भुत संकल्प
शक्ति अदम्य साहस एवं अनुकरणीय सेवा भाव
की मिसाल कायम करते हुए हवलदार माजिद ने
अपने प्राण न्यौछावर कर दिए सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगी उनकी धर्म पत्नी श्रीमती सगरा बी
[प्रशंसा]
शत्रु का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय शौर्य
पूर्ण कार्यों के लिए शौर्य चक्र मरण
उपरांत
कांस्टेबल सेफ उल्लाह कादरी जम्मू एवं
कश्मीर पुलिस मरणों परात
10 अप्रैल
2022 श्रीनगर में चलाए गए एक आतंक विरोधी
तलाशी अभियान के दौरान कांस्टेबल सैफी
उल्लाह ने उच्च रणनीतिक कुशलता का परिचय
देते हुए आतंकियों की सटीक जानकारी हासिल
की एवं आंतरिक घेराबंदी का जिम्मा संभाला
बंधक बनाए गए आम नागरिकों की सुरक्षा
सुनिश्चित करते हुए जो ही आप लक्षित मकान
की ओर बढ़े आतंकियों ने ग्रेनेड फेंकते
हुए ताबड़ तोड़ गोलियां बरसानी शुरू कर दी
अपनी व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की परवाह किए बिना
आपने अद्भुत बहादुरी का परिचय देते हुए दो
कटर आतंकियों को मार गिराया 24 मई 2022 को
एक अन्य ऑपरेशन में अपने आतंकियों का
मुकाबला करते हुए आपने अपना सर्वोच्च
बलिदान दिया सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगे उनके
धर्म पत्नी श्रीमती राबिया मुस्तफा
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर विकास भांबू सेना मेडल मेजर मुस्तफा
बोहरा 252 आर्मी एविएशन स्क्वाड्रन ए एल
एच डब्लू एस आई मरणोपरांत
21 अक्टूबर 2022 को मेजर विकास पायलट के
रूप में और मेजर मुस्तफा कोपायलट के रूप
में अरुणाचल प्रदेश की सीमा पर रुद्र
हेलीकॉप्टर में तैनात सिविलियंस एवं रॉनेस
मिशन पर थे सुबह 10:30 बजे मिशन के दौरान
हेलीकॉप्टर में भयानक आग लग गई और वह तेजी
से नीचे गिरने लगा दोनों पायलट ने जीवन पर
आसन संकट की स्थिति में रहते हुए भी
अनुकरणीय संयम बनाए रखा और एक घातक स्थिति
का सामना किया दोनों बहादुर अधिकारियों ने
अपनी जान की परवाह ना करते हुए विमान का
संचालन किया और आवासीय क्षेत्र से दूर
विमान को उड़ाया परंतु इसी बीच उनका विमान
दुर्घटना ग्रस्त हो गया दोनों शूरवीर
अधिकारियों ने अतः साहस अतुलनीय शौर्य का
अद्वितीय उदाहरण प्रस्तुत किया और भारतीय
सेना की उच्चतम परंपराओं के अनुरूप देश के
लिए सर्वोच्च बलिदान दिया सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगी स्वर्गीय मेजर विकास भाम सेना मेडल
की धर्म पत्नी श्रीमती श्रेया चौधरी एवं
माताज श्रीमती सुखवंत
[प्रशंसा]
स्वर्गीय मेजर मुस्तफा बोहरा की माताजी
श्रीमती फातिमा बोहरा एवं पिताजी श्री जकी
उद्दीन बोहरा
राइफल मैन कुल भूषण मंता बावी बटालियन द
राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स मरणोपरांत
अक्टूबर 2022 में उत्तरी कश्मीर के
बारामुला जिले में ऑपरेशन रक्षक नामक
संयुक्त ऑपरेशन में राइफल मैन कुलभूषण
मनता को तैनात किया गया था प्राप्त
जानकारी के आधार पर राइफल मैन कुलभूषण के
नेतृत्व में तलाशी दल दो आतंकवादियों के
निकट पहुंच गया खतरे को भांपते हुए
आतंकवादियों ने भागने की कोशिश की परंतु
राइफलमैन कुलभूषण ने एक आतंकी को पकड़ा
इसी बीच उनकी आतंकवादी के साथ भारी
मुठभेड़ के दौरान दूसरे आतंकवादी ने उन पर
गोलीबारी शुरू की जिसमें राइफल मैन
कुलभूषण जख्मी हो गए गंभीर चोट के बावजूद
उन्होंने बड़ी बहादुरी से जवाबी कार्रवाई
की एवं एक आतंकवादी को जिंदा पकड़वा या
अपने अदम में साहस से वे अंत सांस तक
आतंकवादी की गोलाबारी का जवाब देते रहे और
अंतत वीर गति को प्राप्त हो गए सम्मान
ग्रहण करेंगी स्वर्गीय राइफल मैन कुलभूषण
मंता की धर्म पत्नी श्रीमती नीतू कुमारी
एवं माता जी श्रीमती दुरमा देवी
[प्रशंसा]
हवलदार विवेक सिंह तोमर पांचवी बटालियन द
राजपूताना राइफल्स मरणोपरांत
10 जनवरी 2023 को सुबह 8 बजे ऑपरेशन
मेघदूत के तहत सेंट्रल ग्लेशियर में
18300 फीट की ऊंचाई पर अग्रिम चौकी पर
तैनात हवलदार विवेक ने एक संतरी पोस्ट पर
धुआं निकलता देखा इस घटना के परिणाम
स्वरूप अग्रिम चौकी पर बड़े पैमाने पर आग
लग सकती थी जिसमें सैनिकों को जान का खतरा
और संपत्ति का भारी नुकसान हो सकता था
स्थिति को नियंत्रित करने के लिए तुरंत वे
तंबू के अंदर गए अपनी जान की परवाह ना
करते हुए वे घने धुएं के बीच घुसे और एक
बड़ी दुर्घटना को काबू में किया परंतु इसी
बीच धुएं के कारण उनकी श्वास नली में
क्षति होने के कारण स्वास्थ्य बिगड़ा और
खराब मौसम के कारण उन्हें वहां से नहीं
निकाला जा सका उन्होंने बड़ी निर्भीकता
पूर्वक 36 घंटे तक इस कठिनाई का सामना
करते हुए देश के लिए अपना सर्वोच्च समर्पण
कर दिया सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगी स्वर्गीय
हवलदार विवेक सिंह तोमर की धर्म पत्नी
श्रीमती रेखा
राइफल मैन आलोक राव 18 आसाम राइफल्स मरण
उपरांत
10 मई 2023 राइफल मैन आलोक राव को लाइट
मशीन गन बंकर में तैनात किया गया तभी
उन्होंने 12 आतंकवादियों को अपने बंकर के
समीप आते देखा और उन्होंने अपने साथियों
की मदद से आतंकवादियों को चेतावनी दी
परंतु आतंकवादियों ने उनके दल पर फायरिंग
शुरू कर दी इसी गोलाबारी के बीच उन्होंने
सटीक जवाबी हमला कर तीन आतंकवादियों को
घायल किया और अपने अदम में साहस का परिचय
देते हुए अपने साथियों की जान बचाई
दुर्भाग्य से इस गोलीबारी के बीच वे गंभीर
रूप से घायल हुए और देश के लिए अपना
सर्वस्व न्योछावर कर गए सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगी स्वर्गीय राइफल मैन आलोक राव की
माताजी श्रीमती माया देवी एवं पिताजी श्री
विजय कुमार
कैप्टन एम व प्रांजल 6वी बटालियन द
राष्ट्र राइफल्स मरणोपरांत
222 नवंबर सन 2023 को राजौरी जिले के घने
जंगल वाले क्षेत्र में आतंकवादियों की
मौजूदगी की सूचना प्राप्त हुई तभी कैप्टन
एमवी प्रांजल को जंगल के निकट आबादी वाले
क्षेत्र में निगरानी ऑपरेशन दल के नेतृत्व
की जिम्मेदारी को सौंपा गया जल्द ही उनका
आतंकवादियों से सामना हुआ और उसी बीच
आतंकवादियों ने उनके दल पर भारी गोलीबारी
शुरू कर दी स्थानीय निवासियों पर संकट को
भांपते हुए उन्होंने बड़ी बहादुरी से अपनी
सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए नागरिकों को
खतरे से बाहर निकाला और अपने साथियों की
मदद से आतंकवादियों की गोलाबारी का
अद्वितीय साहस से जवाब दिया परंतु इसी बीच
वे गंभीर रूप से घायल हो गए और अंततः वीर
गति को प्राप्त हुए सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगी
स्वर्गीय कैप्टन एम व प्रांजल की पत्नी
श्रीमती अदिति जी मुद बिहाल करर एवं माता
जी श्रीमती अनुराधा के आर
[प्रशंसा]
शत्रु का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय असाधारण
वीरता के लिए कीर्ति चक्र मेजर दिग्विजय
सिंह रावत एकस बटालियन पैराशूट रेजीमेंट
स्पेशल फोर्सेस
आपने अपनी बटालियन के साथ मणिपुर में
तैनाती के दौरान उच्च व्यावसायिक का परिचय
देते हुए एक सशक्त निगरानी ग्रिड स्थापित
किया 26 मार्च 2023 को आपको मणिपुर में
आने वाले एक अति गणमान्य व्यक्ति को
उपद्रवियों द्वारा निशाना बनाने के
संभावित प्रयास की सूचना मिली उत्कृष्ट
रणनीतिक कुशलता से आपने उपद्रवियों को
सफलता पूर्वक लक्षित क्षेत्र की ओर मोड़ते
हुए भारी गोलीबारी के बीच एक उपद्रवी को
मार गिराया एवं दूसरे को घायल कर दिया इसी
प्रकार अद्वितीय साहस एवं अनुकरणीय
कर्तव्य निष्ठा का प्रदर्शन करते हुए एक
अन्य अभिमान अभियान में आपने तीन खतरनाक
उपद्रवियों को आमने सामने की लड़ाई में
परास्त करते हुए जिंदा पकड़ने में सफलता
हासिल की मेजर दिग्विजय सिंह रावत
[प्रशंसा]
[संगीत]
मेजर दीपेंद्र विक्रम बस्नेट चौथी बटालियन
द सिख रेजीमेंट
आपने 15 जून 2023 को केरन सेक्टर में
नियंत्रण रेखा पर पांच आतंकियों द्वारा
संदिग्ध घुसपैठ की सूचना के आधार पर तैनात
एक एंबुश दल का नेतृत्व किया मध्यरात्रि
के बाद एंबुश में फंसे आतंकियों ने
ग्रेनेड के साथ हमला करते हुए तीव्र
गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी अपने साथियों को
प्राणघातक खतरे में देख आप निडरता से रकते
हुए आगे बढ़े और एक आतंकी को अपने सटीक
निशाने से एवं दूसरे को आमने सामने की
लड़ाई में अपने चाकू से मौत के घाट उतार
दिया अद्भुत मानसिक संयम विशिष्ट बदरी एवं
रण कौशल का परिचय देते हुए आपने एक सफल
अभियान को अंजाम दिया जिसमें पांच सशस्त्र
विदेशी आतंकियों को मार गिराया गया मेजर
दीपेंद्र विक्रम बस्नेट
[प्रशंसा]
हवलदार वर्तमान में नायब सूबेदार पवन
कुमार यादव 21वी बटालियन द महार
रेजीमेंट 22 जून
2023 कुपवाड़ा के घने जंगलों में कुछ
आतंकवादियों की संदिग्ध घुसपैठ की सूचना
के आधार पर एंबुश का निर्णय लिया गया
हवलदार पवन कुमार एवं उनके साथियों ने
अद्भुत संकल्प शक्ति के साथ नियंत्रण रेखा
पर दुश्मन की चौकी के बेहद नजदीक निरंतर
कड़ी निगरानी बनाए रखी एंबुश में फंसते ही
आतंकियों द्वारा की जा रही भीषण गोलीबारी
के बीच घने जंगल एवं माइनफील्ड के क्षेत्र
में अपने प्राणों की परवाह ना करते हुए आप
रेंगते हुए आगे बढ़े अदम्य साहस एवं युद्ध
कौशल का परिचय देते हुए आपने एक आतंकी को
अपने सटीक निशाने से एवं दूसरे भागते हुए
आतंकी को गुथ गुत्ता की लड़ाई में मार
गिराया हवलदार वर्तमान में नायब सूबेदार
पवन कुमार यादव
[प्रशंसा]
शत्रु का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय शौर्य
पूर्ण कार्यों के लिए शौर्य चक्र
कांस्टेबल गामित मुकेश कुमार 61 बटालियन
केंद्रीय रिजर्व पुलिस
बल 19 दिसंबर
20221 श्रीनगर में चलाए गए एक आतंक विरोधी
तलाशी अभियान में भाग लेते समय आप यूं ही
अपने साथी के साथ लक्षित मकान में घुसे
वहां छिपे कट्टर आतंकवादी ने ग्रेनेड
फेंकते हुए अंधा धुंद गोलियां बरसानी शुरू
कर दी उत्कृष्ट रणनीतिक सूझबूझ अदम साहस
अनुकरणीय दृढ़ संकल्प का परिचय देते हुए
आपने अपने साथी को इस प्राणघातक हमले से
बचाया एवं भागते हुए कट्टर आतंकी को बेहद
नजदीक से मार गिराया जिसके पास हथियार एवं
गोला बारूद बरामद किया गया कांस्टेबल
गामित मुकेश कुमार
[प्रशंसा]
उपनिरीक्षक अमित रैना जम्मू एवं कश्मीर
पुलिस 3 जनवरी 2022 को श्रीनगर के शहरी
इलाकों में कुछ सशस्त्र आतंकियों के मौजूद
होने की सूचना के आधार पर सशस्त्र बलों
द्वारा एक संयुक्त अभियान चलाया गया अपने
साथियों के साथ मिलकर आपने आतंकियों के
भागने के सभी संभावित रास्तों को बंद करते
हुए आम नागरिकों को सुरक्षित स्थान पर
पहुंचाया आप जूं ही लक्षित मकान की ओर
बढ़े वहां छिपे आतंकियों ने ग्रेनेड से
हमला करते हुए आप पर भीषण गोलीबारी शुरू
कर दी अपनी जान की परवाह किए बिना आप
आतंकी की ओर बढ़े और आमने सामने की
गोलीबारी में एक कट्टर आतंकी को बेहद
नजदीक से मार गिराया उत्कृष्ट नेतृत्व
क्षमता असाधारण वीरता का प्रदर्शन करते
हुए आपने एक अभियान को सफलता पूर्वक अंजाम
तक पहुंचाया उपनिरीक्षक अमित रैना
[प्रशंसा]
उपनिरीक्षक फरोज अहमद दार जम्मू एवं
कश्मीर
पुलिस 3 जनवरी 2022 को उपनिरीक्षक फरोज
अहमद दार को दोपहर 2 बजे विश्वसनीय
सूत्रों से श्रीनगर में एक दुर्दांत
आतंकवादी की उपस्थिति के बारे में सूचना
मिली जो कई नागरिकों तथा पुलिस कर्मियों
की हत्या के लिए जिम्मेदार था सूचना के
आधार पर आपने अपनी टीम के साथ इलाके का
घेराव किया नागरिकों और पर्यटकों की
सुरक्षा का ध्यान रखते हुए उपनिरीक्षक
फरोज अहमद डार ने कठिन परिस्थितियों में
आतंकवादी को चिन्हित किया खतरा भांपते ही
आतंकवादी ने गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी आम
नागरिकों और पर्यटकों की सुरक्षा का ध्यान
रखकर उपनिरीक्षक फरोज अहमद डार ने अपनी
जान की परवाह ना करते हुए भारी गोली बारी
के बीच आमने सामने की मुठभेड़ में एक
दुर्दांत आतंकवादी को मार गिराया विपरीत
परिस्थितियों में ऐसी अतुलनीय वीरता विवेक
एवं शौर्य के प्रदर्शन के लिए उपनिरीक्षक
फरोज अहमद डार को शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित
किया जाता है उप निरीक्षक फरोज अहमद दार
[प्रशंसा]
सहायक कमांडेंट विभोर कुमार सिंह 205
कमांडो बटालियन फॉर रेसलूट एक्शन केंद्रीय
रिजर्व पुलिस बल
25 फरवरी 2022 को सहायक कमांडेंट विभोर
कुमार सिंह औरंगाबाद के नक्सलवाद ग्रस्त
इलाके में एक सर्च एंड डिस्ट्रॉय ऑपरेशन
टीम का नेतृत्व कर रहे थे घने जंगल में
पेड़ों और चट्टानों की सुरक्षित आड़ में
छुपे नक्सलवादियों ने सर्च टीम पर भारी
गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी इस दौरान सहायक
कमांडेंट विभोर कुमार सिंह का बाया पैर एक
आईडी विस्फोट से क्तिग होकर कट गया असीम
पीड़ा को अपनी सहनशीलता संकल्प और इच्छा
शक्ति से पराजित करते हुए सहायक कमांडेंट
विभोर कुमार सिंह ने कवरिंग फायर के साथ
मोर्चा संभाला कटे हुए पैर के साथ भी अपने
दल का नेतृत्व कर आप उन्हें आगे बढ़ने के
लिए प्रोत्साहित करते रहे और कवरिंग फायर
देकर ऑपरेशन को सफल बनाया ऐसे अनुकरणीय
साहस सैन्य नेत
एवं वीरत युद्ध कौशल को परिभाषित करने के
लिए सहायक कमांडेंट विभोर कुमार सिंह को
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है
सहायक कमांडेंट विभोर कुमार सिंह
[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
कांस्टेबल वरुण सिंह जम्मू एवं कश्मीर
पुलिस 12 जून 2022 को कांस्टेबल वरुण सिंह
श्रीनगर में कुछ अज्ञात आतंकवादियों
द्वारा अवैध हथियार और गोला बारू छिपाए
जाने की खबर पर आतंकवादियों के खिलाफ गठित
किए गए एक तलाशी अभियान का हिस्सा थे
संभावित इलाके की घेराबंदी कर तलाशी
अभियान शुरू किया गया इस दौरान
आतंकवादियों ने टीम पर अंधाधुंध फायरिंग
के साथ ग्रेनेड से हमला शुरू कर दिया
कांस्टेबल वरुण सिंह अपनी टीम के साथ
आतंकवादियों की तरफ बढ़े आतंकवादियों ने
पुलिस टीम को अपनी तरफ बढ़ता देख गोलियां
चलाई अपने साथी को खतरे में देख कांस्टेबल
वरुण सिंह ने उन्हें तेजी से जमीन की ओर
खींचा और अपने साथी की जान बचाई अपने
प्राणों के संकट को उपेक्षित करते हुए
निस्वार्थ भाव से कांस्टेबल वरुण सिंह ने
अपनी सैन्य निपुणता से भीषण मुठ बेर में
एक दुर्दांत आतंकवादी को मार गिराया जिसके
कब्जे से भारी मात्रा में युद्ध सामग्री
बरामद की गई विपरीत परिस्थितियों में
कटिबद्ध पराक्रम एवं उच्च कोटि के रण कौशल
का प्रदर्शन करने के लिए कांस्टेबल वरुण
सिंह को शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता
है कांस्टेबल वरुण सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
पुलिस अधीक्षक मोहन लाल जम्मू कश्मीर
पुलिस 14 जून 2022 को जिला श्रीनगर के
बेमिना क्षेत्र में अवैध हथियार ले जाने
वाले आतंकवादियों की गतिविधि के बारे में
सूचना प्राप्त हुई तत्काल पुलिस अधीक्षक
मोहनलाल के नेतृत्व में एक विशेष नाका
स्थापित किया गया जैसे ही आतंकी इस नाके
के समीप पहुंच तो उन्होंने नाका दल पर
अंधाधुंध गोलीबारी एवं ग्रेनेड फेंकने
शुरू किए जिससे अधिकारी को गंभीर चोट आई
परंतु फिर भी बहादुर अधिकारी ने अत्यधिक
चुनौतीपूर्ण क्षेत्र में अपनी व्यक्तिगत
सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए अपनी सामरिक
युद्ध कौशल होता का उच्च उदाहरण पेश किया
और दो आतंकवादियों को मार गिराया पुलिस
अधीक्षक मोहनलाल
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर राजेंद्र प्रसाद जाट 6वी बटालियन द
राष्ट्र
राइफल्स मेजर राजेंद्र प्रसाद जाट को
ऑपरेशन वटर हॉल के नेतृत्व की जिम्मेदारी
को सौंपा गया तभी रवीर अधिकारी ने एक सटीक
योजना बनाई और खराब मौसम के बावजूद
सैनिकों का नेतृत्व किया और आतंकवादियों
को एक घर के अंदर घेर लिया अपनी सामरिक
युद्ध कौशल होता का प्रदर्शन करते हुए
उन्होंने आतंकवादियों पर प्रभावी ढंग से
आक्रमण किया परंतु जवाबी कार्रवाई में
उनके एक साथी पर घातक खतरे को भांपते हुए
अपनी व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते
हुए वे आगे बढ़े और एक कट्टर आतंकवादी को
मार गिराया एवं दूसरे को घायल किया मेजर
राजेंद्र प्रसाद
[प्रशंसा]
जाट मेजर रविंद्र सिंह रावत 44 व बटालियन
द राष्ट्र राइफल्स
30 अगस्त 2022 को शोपिया जिले के एक गांव
में तीन आतंकवादियों की मौजूदगी की सूचना
प्राप्त हुई प्रारंभिक घेराबंदी करते समय
अधिकारी ने तीन आतंकवादियों को घने जंगल
की ओर भागते देखा उसी बीच आतंकियों ने
घेरा तोड़ने की कोशिश की और अधिकारी की ओर
अंधा धुंध गोलीबारी की तभी त्वरित
कार्रवाई करते हुए उन्होंने प्रभावी ढंग
से आतंकवादियों को मुंह तोड़ जवाब एवं दो
आतंकवादियों को मार गिराया मेजर रविंद्र
सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
रावत नायक भीम सिंह नौवी बटालियन द
राष्ट्र राइफल्स
26 सितंबर 2022 को दक्षिण कश्मीर के एक
गांव में आतंकवादी समूह की मौजूदगी के
बारे में सूचना प्राप्त हुई तभी नायक भीम
सिंह ने घेराबंदी एवं तलाशी अभियान का
नेतृत्व संभालने की जिम्मेदारी सौंपी गई
जब वे नागरिकों को ऑपरेशन क्षेत्र से बाहर
निकाल रहे थे तभी आतंकियों ने उनकी टीम पर
अ धुंद फायरिंग शुरू कर दी और ग्रेनेड से
हमला कर एक अधिकारी को घायल कर दिया तभी
उन्होंने जवाबी कार्रवाई में सटीक
गोलीबारी से आतंकवादी को मार गिराया और
घायल अधिकारी को सुरक्षित बाहर निकाला
आपके अदम्य साहस अद्वितीय नेतृत्व एवं
अतुलनीय शौर्य के प्रदर्शन हेतु आपको
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है नायक
भीम सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर सचिन नेगी द ग्रेनेडियर पच बटालियन द
राष्ट्रीय
राइफल्स मेजर सचिन नेगी ने ने नवंबर 2020
से राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स के कार्यकाल के
दौरान कई सफल अभियानों में भाग लिया
जिसमें उनके बटालियन द्वारा 14 आतंकियों
का खात्मा किया गया 1 नवंबर 2022 को आपने
पुलवामा जिले में एक वाहन चेक पोस्ट
स्थापित किया चुनौती दिए जाने पर एक वाहन
में सवार आतंकियों ने गोलीबारी करते हुए
आप पर ग्रेनेड से हमला कर दिया अद्भुत
संयम एवं सामरिक कौशल के साथ अपने भागने
के रास्तों को बंद करते हुए अपने दल को
सुनि सुनियोजित किया और रेंगते हुए
आतंकवादियों की ओर बढ़े अपने प्राणों की
चिंता किए बिना अपने एक आतंकी को बेहद
नजदीक से मार गिराया एवं एक अन्य को घायल
करते हुए अदम साहस एवं अनुकरणीय नेतृत्व
का परिचय दिया मेजर सचिन नेगी
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर मने फ्रांसिस पीएफ 21 बटालियन द
पैराशूट रेजीमेंट स्पेशल
फोर्सेस आपने मणिपुर में अपनी बटालियन के
लिए एक सक्षम निगरानी तंत्र स्थापित करते
हुए आतंकवादी गतिविधियों की सटीक जानकारी
प्राप्त की चार जनवरी 2023 एक गणमान्य
व्यक्ति पर आतंकी द्वारा किए जाने वाले
संभावित हमले की सूचना मिलते ही आपने उनके
गुजरने के रास्तों को चिन्हित किया और घात
लगाकर उनके प्रयासों को विफल करने की
योजना बनाई चुनौती दिए जाने पर आतंकियों
ने स्वचालित हथियारों से गोलियां बरसाते
हुए भागने का प्रयास किया उच्च युद्ध कौशल
एवं अनुकरणीय नेतृत्व क्षमता का परिचय
देते हुए आप आतंकवादियों पर टूट पड़े और
उनके कमांडर को मौत के घाट उतार दिया तथा
अन उग्रवादी को घायल कर दिया मेजर मने
फ्रांसिस
[प्रशंसा]
पीएफ बंग कमांडर शैलेश सिंह उड़ान पायलट
वक मंडर शैले सिंह को एक बेहद साहसिक हेली
बन ऑपरेशन के उड़ान पायलट की जिम्मेदारी
सौंपी गई एक ऐसा अभियान जिसमें ने जंगलों
में कम ऊंचाई पर दुश्मन की संभावित
गोलीबारी के बीच उड़ान भरते हुए अपने दल
को एक छोटी सी खाली जगह पर उतारने की
चुनौती थी आपका हेलीकॉप्टर जों ही लैंडिंग
क्षेत्र के पास उतरने के करीब था चारों ओर
से स्वचालित हथियारों द्वारा भयंकर
गोलीबारी शुरू हो गई अद्वितीय सामरिक
सूझबूझ के साथ आपने जबाबी फायरिंग का आदेश
दिया गोलियां लगने से हेलीकॉप्टर
क्षतिग्रस्त होने के अलावा आपके कुछ साथी
भी जख्मी हो चुके थे ईंधन के लगातार हो
रहे रिसाव के कारण आग लगने एवं विस्फोट का
खतरा निरंतर बढ़ रहा था ऐसी प्राण घातक
परिस्थितियों से जूझते हुए इस शूरवीर वायु
योद्धा ने 22 किमी दूर निकटतम हेलीपैड पर
अपने साथियों को सुरक्षित पहुंचाया इस
प्रकार भारतीय वायु सेना की उच्चतम
परंपराओं के अनुरूप अनुकरणीय कर्तव्य
परायणता एवं उच्च उड़ान कौशल की मिसाल
कायम की विन कमांडर शैलेश सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
लेफ्टनंट विमल रंजन बेहरा कमांड क्लीयरेंस
डाइविंग टीम ईस्टर्न नेवल
कमांड 6 मार्च
2023 ओएनजीसी द्वारा बंगाल की खाड़ी में
उनके जलयान के इंजन एवं टट में मछली
पकड़ने के जाल उलझने से आई खराबी की
आपातकालीन परिस्थितियों में भारतीय नौसेना
के गोताखोरों की सहायता मांगी गई लेफ्टनंट
बमल प्रमुख गोताखोर के रूप में निडरता से
आगे बढ़े मुश्किल हालात में पानी की भारी
उथल पुथल ने आपको तीव्र गति से धकेला
जिससे आप एक भारी जंजीर में जा फसे पानी
के प्रबल प्रवाह में कुछ इंच आगे बढ़ना भी
बेहद चुनौतीपूर्ण था इसके बावजूद आप लगभग
100 फीट की दूरी तैरकर टट तक पहुंच गए
अपने सा की जान जोखिम ना डालते हुए इस
जांबाज गोताखोर ने खुद ही अधिकांश
प्रयासों को अंजाम दिया जटिल उपकरणों से
लगे तीखे घावों के बावजूद आपने दो चरणों
में 552 मिनट तक 16 बार गोता लगाते हुए इस
चुनौतीपूर्ण अभियान को अंजाम दिया
लेफ्टनंट विमल रंजन बेहेरा
[प्रशंसा]
हवलदार संजय कुमार नौमी बटालियन द आसाम
राइफल्स 13 मई
2023 हवलदार संजय कुमार मणिपुर में तैनात
थे उनके दल को चार उग्रवादियों की मौजूदगी
की सूचना मिलते ही वह तुरंत उस क्षेत्र
में पहुंची आपने कुछ दूरी पर दो सशस्त्र
उग्रवादियों को आते देखा आपकी चुनौती देने
पर सशस्त्र आतंकियों ने स्वचालित हथियारों
से गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी दाई टांग पर गोली
लगने के बावजूद आपने अदम्य साहस एवं
अनुकरणीय सूझबूझ का परिचय देते हुए अपने
दल को सुव्यवस्थित किया एवं हल्की मशीन गन
को ऊंचाई पर तैनात किया आपके प्रेरणादायक
नेतृत्व एवं सामरिक सूझबूझ के कारण
सशस्त्र उग्रवादियों पर काबू पाया गया
आपने साहसिक अभियान में अद्भुत शौर्य एवं
कर्तव्य परायणता का परिचय दिया हवलदार
संजय
[प्रशंसा]
कुमार फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट ऋषिकेश जयन करु
थड़क 24 मई 2023 को फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट
ऋषिकेश पठानकोट से दिल्ली तक एक
ट्रांसपोर्ट विमान का संचालन कर रहे थे
तभी किसी तकनीकी रुकावट की वजह से उन्हें
गंभीर खतरे का आभास हुआ और दिल्ली
अंतरराष्ट्रीय हवाई अड्डे पर सघन एयर
ट्रैफिक को देखते हुए उन्होंने वायुयान को
को हिंडन एयरपोर्ट की तरफ ले जाकर
अतिरिक्त इंजन का प्रयोग कर बेली लैंडिंग
करने का फैसला किया और अपनी स्थिति जन्य
सूज भूज का परिचय देते हुए विपरीत
परिस्थितियों में भी शौर्य और दक्षता को
परिभाषित किया एवं अनुकरणीय पराक्रम का
प्रदर्शन कर विमान में सवार यात्रियों की
जान बचाई फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट ऋषिकेश जयन
करुथड़ाई
[प्रशंसा]
कैप्टन अक्षत उपाध्याय बीस बटालियन द जाट
रेजीमेंट 2728 मई 2023 को मध्य रात्रि को
कैप्टन अक्षत उपाध्याय और उनके दल ने एक
अस्थाई ऑपरेटिंग बेस स्थापित किया सुबह के
लगभग 3:00 बजे उन्होंने थोड़ी दूरी पर
गांव के एक घर में आग लगते हुए देखा और एक
बड़ी भीड़ को गांव की तरफ आगे बढ़ते हुए
देखा तभी अधिकारी ने कुशलता से अपने दल को
तैनात किया और लुमिनेशन राउंड फायर किया
जैसे ही फायर किया गया जलते हुए घर की
दिशा से भारी ऑटोमेटिक गोलीबारी होने लगी
इसी बीच वे तुरंत कुशलता पूर्वक आगे बढ़े
और आतंकियों की गोलाबारी का सटीक जवाब
दिया जिसके फल स्वरूप चार आतंकवादी मारे
गए और लगभग 200 ग्रामीणों को सुरक्षित
किया गया अत्यंत वीरता अद्वितीय साहस एवं
सामरिक कौशल का उच्चतम उदाहरण प्रस्तुत
किया कैप्टन अक्षत उपाध्याय
[प्रशंसा]
नायब सूबेदार बारिया संजय कुमार भमर सिंह
21वी बटालियन द महर
रेजिमेंट 12 जून 2023 को चार से पांच
आतंकियों के घुसपैठ की सूचना प्राप्त हुई
तभी नायब सूबेदार बारिया संजय को एक घात
टुकड़ी का हिस्सा बनाया गया उन्होंने घने
जंगल में अपनी सूझबूझ का उत्कृष्ट
प्रदर्शन दिया और आतंकवादियों के निकट
पहुंचे अपनी जान की परवाह ना करते हुए
तुरंत परिस्थिति को अपने नियंत्रण में
लिया और प्रभावी रूप से आतंकवादियों का
सामना कर एक कट्टर आतंकवादी को मार गिराया
आपने असाधारण वीरता अदम में साहस और देश
सेवा के प्रति अत्यधिक समर्पण का परिचय
दिया नायब सूबेदार बारिया संजय कुमार भमर
सिंह
मेजर अमनदीप जाखड़ चौथी बटालियन द सीख
रेजीमेंट मेजर अमनदीप जाखड़ दिनाक 15 जून
2023 को नियंत्रण रेखा के निकट कुपवाड़ा
जिले के केरन सेक्टर में तैनात एक घात
टुकड़ी का हिस्सा थे 16 जून 2023 को जैसे
ही यह घात टुकड़ी ऑपरेशन के लिए रवाना हुई
तभी दो आतंकवादियों ने उनकी टीम पर अंधा
धुंद फायरिंग करते हुए भागने का प्रयास
किया बहादुर अधिकारी ने भारी गोलाबारी में
भी कुशलता से आतंकवादियों का पीछा किया और
दोनों आतंकवादियों को मार गिराया मेजर
अमनदीप ने अपनी सैन्य टुकड़ियों को बचाने
के लिए अपनी जान जोखिम में डाली और ऑपरेशन
को सफल किया मेजर मन दीप
[प्रशंसा]
खड़ श्री पुरुषोत्तम
कुमार आप जिला जौरी में खेतीबाड़ी संभालते
हैं एवं ग्राम रक्षा समिति के सदस्य हैं 5
अगस्त 2023 को वह अपने परिवार के साथ जंगल
में लकड़ी चुन रहे थे तभी उन्होंने पीठ पर
शस्त्रों से लेस दो संदिग्ध व्यक्तियों को
देखा तुरंत उन्हें गांव पर आसन खतरे का
आभास हुआ और उन्होंने चुपचाप अपने परिवार
को सदस्य को सुरक्षित घर छोड़ा एवं ग्राम
रक्षा समिति पुलिस और सेना को सचेत करते
हुए अपना व्यक्तिगत हथियार लिया जब
सुरक्षा बल घेराबंदी कर रहे थे उस दौरान
आपने अपनी व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की किंचित भी
परवाह ना करते हुए अदम में साहस और
उत्कृष्ट रण कौशल होता से दोनों आतंकियों
का पीछा किया और बहुत कम दूरी से उन्हें
ललकारा और सुरक्षा बलों के पहुंचने तक
दोनों आतंकियों से संपर्क बनाए रखा उनकी
इस बहादुरी से एक आतंकवादी मारा गया अता
अद्वितीय सूझबूझ एवं प्रेरक बहादुरी पूर्ण
कार्य के लिए उन्हें शौर चक्र से सम्मानित
किया जाता है श्री पुरुषोत्तम
[प्रशंसा]
कुमार राष्ट्रपति महोदय आपकी आज्ञा है तो
रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह समाप्त किया जाए
[संगीत]
राष्ट्रपति भवन के दरबार हॉल में आयोजित
रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह का पहला चरण अब
संपन्न हो रहा है देश के राष्ट्रपति
माननीय श्रीमती द्रौपदी मुरमू अन्य
विशिष्ट अतिथि